my man Brian James Shaw my big boy Derek
and my girl cat I got a question for you
guys
debate club IPAs this is Donna
background or are y'all about them cheap
beers to [ __ ] chug no get that Miller
Lite hitter that that was walking oh
look at these boys from the moat with
the Berk baby club let me hear it boys
first of all shout out to Bishop gun
playing in the background they're
beautiful
shut up - these two young men having a
nice bubbly you know I'm saying oh yeah
a couple guys in a basement drinking -
this is Midwest light through this is
America mystery this is so goddamn
American goddamn did I salute this [ __ ]
can Oh Brava Wow hi salute to you
[ __ ] I'll attack these guys for oil
bro it's how [ __ ] American I am ah
yes I'll dig up in their backyard
brother bombs yeah mines and [ __ ] praise
God brother I'd like to say this I like
a oh I like a real shitty beer man if
I'm gonna have a beer dude I like to all
right I don't mind if half of it spills
down my [ __ ] shirt you know drowns my
cat whatever dude I don't give a damn
bro now I'll put a little in my fish
tank matter of fact yeah some you can
[ __ ] you know split with your fish
yeah something you can [ __ ] kind of
spice up that flounder by the
old-fashion yeah that Miller High Life
for that [ __ ] scorpion you feel me
yeah a little Miller High Life where
your [ __ ] clown fish it's easy for
two betta fish to fighting Bravo watch
them fight in a [ __ ] little love when
you put a little bit of gin between them
yeah you a Mickey's in that yeah see
what happens they get scrappier I like a
nice IPA listen I like both of them I
like a nice hoppy IPA I like a local
beer you know I'm saying I like a nice
hoppy local beer whatever city I'm in
can't have beer right now cuz I'm the
keto kid yeah so are you the keto kid
yeah I'm down 16 pounds bro really you
know what I started heavy that's very
easy yeah thanks man you seem like the
cheeto kid because yeah Sager oh well
I'm not
you look great manners what I'm trying
to tell you but what this guy is saying
yeah man I think if you're hanging out
with the you get those hoppy beers man
it just tastes all you know reminds me
of my past too much start tape drinking
and tasting remind you of like you know
you're going a wood shop and yeah yeah
being in violence domestic disputes it's
your own demons in the closet don't hate
on all IPA cuz you grew up weird you
know I'm sayin
what a nice hoppy beers out there but I
like that [ __ ] Miller lighting board
bro the kind of [ __ ] that makes you
think you know am I getting a damn car
accident tonight yeah that Coors Light
hitter all down 12 of those insiders is
it Aquafina
or is it bear let's you know I'm
hammered can't see behind the wheel time
yeah it's a fun time I wish the cops had
to guess what you've been drinking in
order to actually give you a DUI yeah
that's a good idea it would be good huh
cuz I like to mix it up I put a piece of
bubble gum in my mouth
good luck boys really yeah if you put
like six or seven pennies in your mouth
I can't tell that you've been drinking
they can tell however you've been hiding
pennies in your mouth that the
detectives will figure out they have
seven cents in you're out there penny
for your thoughts what do we got 58 58
percent cheap beer yeah it's just a good
time they're played Edward forty hands
yeah you're played that game yeah well I
thought it was like a special thing with
me and my friends only it's not it's a
pretty common game ever extremely
popular Wow
yeah you take two 40s chin doesn't know
what it is you take two 40s you duct
tape around your two hands you can't put
them down to finish drinking them mm-hmm
yeah yeah I almost died myself get
people die every year doing that and
what I'm talking about is that sometime
we used to play yeah we'd wear raincoats
and [ __ ] put on listen to some
juvenile and get all [ __ ] up mmm why
the raincoats though I don't know you're
a fan of the Columbine kids or what just
young no not uh you're talking about
wider kind of jacket some talk about
raincoats all right the yellow one yeah
oh all right just in case yeah we can
make amazing
do juvenile did it bro oh he got busted
in a neighborhood next two bars he
chased a woman with a ice pick down the
street oh why cause you're stealing his
beef I don't know what happened he's got
it
just domestic dispute is he a live dog a
still-life is he still making jams
what do do everything what but his main
jams were back there that girl good
won't you back that song called ha - he
had the hot boys the hot boy did you hit
a bunch it's a thing yeah good runner
with little Wayne was with him too hot
boys ID 9 yeah he was like 9 rapping
with [ __ ] juvenile yeah man BG got on
the drugs that thank you
what was he but you had a he's that you
want you're fine I love talking about
you back that up but he had one more
that we he had one more that will slap
your nuts dude
Big Tymers he was in big tyrants do some
turns over we get a mug shot from my man
all the pictures you know any pictures
the Isles online you gotta use a mug
shoppers we could Pete if I can hang
eaters but I think I get a couple of
motion slow motion for me slow motion
for me
do you remember that one she were
connect back I don't know how to ex no
[ __ ] hit it that's a comedy - is
genius that's good let's get our it hell
yeah
they played this in my grandmother's
funeral damn makes you want to hit
somebody
this is his number one yeah this is
about being a chiropractor most of it
her neck and her back hurting too fast
god damn day boy I don't know what else
they got hello Hey sorry gonna think
it's called can't take calls from
friends than a Miller I show
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching